زخم كبير عاشته وتعيشه السعوديه الشهر
الحالي سياسيا واقتصاديا وحتى رياضيا
الزميله يشهد المتروك تعرفنا على ابرز
الاحداث التي عاشتها السعوديه منذ مطلع
يونيو
يونيو ساخن تعيشه السعوديه على جميع
الاصعده زخم كبير سياسي واقتصادي يوطد
مكانه الرياض وريادتها في الاقليمي
والعالم نبدا من لقاء ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان بوزير الخارجيه
الامريكي في جده تناول اللقاء قضايا
المنطقه وعلى راسها مكافحه الارهاب وسبل
تحقيق السلام في اليمن فضلا عن تعميق
التعاون الاقتصادي والعلمي بين الرياض
وواشنطن وزير الخارجيه الاميركيه قال
اثناء مغادرته السعوديه انه سعيد بما وصفه
بالسبل الجديده للتعاون مع شركاء
السعوديين مؤكدا العمل مع الرياض للتصدي
للتحديات العالميه
من الزخم السياسي نتحول الى قرار اقتصادي
لا يقل اهميه وهو خفض الانتاج في اوبك بلس
صاحبته ردود فعل واسعه بين مؤيد ومعارض
لسياسه السعوديه التي تقود الحلف احدث
ردود الفعل جاءت قبل ايام من الكرملين حيث
قال المتحدث باسم الرئاسه الروسيه
ان السعوديه دوله مسؤوله ولاعب مهم في
اسواق الطاقه وليست بحاجه لاي وصايه او
مواعظ على حد تعبيره دعونا نذكر او نذكر
بتصريحات وزير الطاقه السعودي الامير عبد
العزيز بن سلمان الذي اكد ان السعوديه ليس
لديها عقده المضاربين في اسواق النفط
لا احنا ما عندنا عقده مضاربين يمكن في
منحاول يدفع بهذا كثير لكن
هي زي اللي مارسناها في عام 21
اعتقد انه كل اجراءاتنا الاخيره حتى في
شهر ابريل تخفيض اللي سوت الدول المشاركه
معنا
لمنفرده سويتك كقرار منفرد لكل دوله هو
قرار تحوطي في السادس من يونيو شهدت
العاصمه السعوديه اعاده فتح السفاره
الايرانيه في خطوه ضمن اتفاقي بكين الشهير
وكانت الخارجيه الايرانيه قد عينت علي رضا
عنايتي سفيرا جديدا لدى السعوديه ويشغل
عنايه حاليا منصب نائب وزير الخارجيه
بعدما كان سفيرا في الكويت
لا تنتهي حيث استضافت السعوديه مؤتمر
الرجال الاعمال العرب والصينيين نتجت عنه
اتفاقيات ضخمه بقيمه اجماليه بلغت عشره
مليارات دولار شملت 30 صفقه طريقه حرير
عصريه جديده تربط الصين بالعالم العربي
كشف عنها وزير الاستثمار السعودي المهندس
خالد الفالح في تطور لافت لاتساع العلاقات
مع بكين
من اليوم ومن خلال هذا المؤتمر على اطلاق
طريق حرير عصريه جديده يكون محركها رؤيتنا
للتعاون والتشارك ووقود انطلاقتها هم
شبابنا وكذلك ابتكاراتنا لنحقق مصالحنا
ومصالح شركائنا في كل انحاء العالم